[Music] I don't know
how it was. It was a lot of fun. It's even
more true than I thought. Well, it was just
that much fun. But it was a
meaningless day where I didn't get anything out of it. I'm
sorry, it's not something I should apologize for.
Everyone's feelings are different, so
I'm glad you didn't try to hide your feelings and tell me your honest feelings Well, I can't help it, but it was pointless Today wasn't
worth spending today Let's just pretend it never
happened
[Music]
Yeah, the negatives are data too.  If you take out all the photos, you'll
lose the record itself.Sorry, you can't lose something you don't have,
but AI is afraid of losing it now.That
means that AI has something now.  Isn't this the best proof that
AI has gained something today? It can't be
expressed in words or converted into scores or evaluations. It
may be useless in the future,
but I don't want to lose it.  I
was gaining something so valuable that I thought to myself,
[Music]
Yo
Ah.